yo your freshman cover is one of the
most legendary freshman covers ever
thank you can you give us like a a story
about that day that shoot like what was
like one of your fondest memories of
shooting um my fondest memory was
probably we all went to the studio the
night before
uh me currency
uh shipes had brought uh
nip through
french was there big charm was there
um
yeah we all just went to the studio that
night and that was the first time i ever
have uh halal food you ever had
yeah of course and the first time i had
it was in new york too yeah yeah so like
y'all gotta [ __ ] have halal so we all
came to the studio and we smoked hey
hello we figured out that [ __ ] is like
10 bucks later like it's not [ __ ]
exotic at all it's like at a cart
outside yeah
but it was bomb it was like a cool new
york [ __ ] yeah and like we wrote three
or four songs like all together me
currency knit
uh big sean
and french like we all sat in the studio
and just wrote some songs together were
these records [ __ ] some ended up on
currencies mixtape at the time some
ended up on nips mixtape at the time
some ended up on french mixtape at the
time some ended up on my mixtape at the
time so they all like scattered they
were scattered around yeah yeah but you
could like go back and check the footage
out there's footage from day to day on
there and uh yeah it was cool i think
like the whole photo shoot was more of a
blur because there was so many [ __ ] in
there and they was trying to interview
us and it was trying to
you know uh
uh
it was just it was a lot of you know
when you got young energy like i knew
what i was doing but a lot of other
people were like
you know what i'm saying so
it was pretty standoffish like at the
shoot